جلسوا تحدثوا وتفرقوا بهذه الكلمات تهكم
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان على انفراط
عقد المعارضه التركيه بعد فشلها باختيار
مرشحها لرئاسه الجمهوريه حتى الان وتعد
هذه الانتخابات مشاهدينا واحده من اهم
السباقات الانتخابيه في تاريخ تركيا
الحديث بالنسبه الى الحكومه وللمعارضه على
حد سواء حيث يسعى اردوغان لترسيخ حكمه في
الذكرى المئويه لتاسيس الجمهوريه التركيه
الانقسام العلني والمحتدم منذ شهور في
صفوف المعارضه التركيه مشاهدينا فتح نافذه
امل اكبر لاردوغان للبقاء في الحكم يقول
الخبراء رغم التحديات التي يواجهها واهمها
تراجع شعبيته فضلا عن انتقادات لطريقه
التعامل مع الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
البلاد الشهر الماضي وعوده بحياه اكثر من
45 الف شخص في تركيا بالاضافه الى ازمه
غلاء نعيشه التي تضرب البلاد رفقه تدني
قيمه العمله المحليه امام الدولار ولكن
مشاهدينا السقوط سقوط المعارضه بفوضى
الانقسام فيما بينها سيكون بمثابه هديه
مجانيه لاردوغان ان حصل ذلك وبالتالي
سيخلط الاوراق السياسيه من جديد لصالح
اردوغان بعد عقدين من الحكم اما تفاصيل
الخلاف بين المعارضه التركيه فبدت واضحه
بعد ان عاشت تركيا اجواء سياسيه شديده
السخونه والتوتر على وقع الزلزال السياسي
الذي احدثه الموقف الصادم
لرئيسه حزب
الجيد ميرال التي اعلنت رفضها ترشيحها
طاوله السته اي تحالف الاحزاب السته
المعارضه زعيم المعارضه رئيس حزب الشعب
الجمهوري كمالك للرئاسه كمرشح مشترك لهذه
الاحزاب المعارضه السته في الانتخابات
المقرره في الرابع عشر من مايو المقبل هذا
الموقف قبل بموقف استهجان واسع من الشارع
التركي وضربت موجه استقالات واسعه حزبها
وتم رصد استقالات اذن كبيره في صفوف هذا
الحزب
[موسيقى]